when cooking in the kitchen it's very
important to use the best tools for the
job
this will ensure maximum flavor as well
as optimal textures
hi my name is alexis and today we're
going to talk about the difference
between
three common household pans let's start
with a nonstick pan
this is probably the most common pan for
beginner cooks these are fairly
inexpensive and due to their non-stick
surface they're super easy to clean
to increase the longevity of your pan
you need to ensure that you're taking
proper care of the non-stick surface
for example when you're making scrambled
eggs you should always be using silicone
or wooden tools
and that goes for all other dishes as
well to get the best results from your
non-stick pan we recommend you cook
delicate dishes like eggs pancakes
grilled cheese and lighter fish such as
tilapia
proteins like steak chicken thighs
burgers or salmon aren't ideal for a
non-stick pan
as those require high heat if you're
looking for easy cleanup and don't want
to make dishes that require high heat
this is the pan for you so now let's
talk about cast irons
i think everybody should own one of
these pans cast iron pans are
exceptionally versatile
these sturdy pans can be used on the
stovetop as well as in the oven
cast iron pans are not only affordable
but if you take proper care of them they
can last for decades
these long-lasting pans can be used to
cook an array of dishes
from steak fruit cobbler and even
frittata you can cook nearly everything
with a cast iron pan
but for beginner cooks they may seem
intimidating
hands need to be treated before their
first use and the cleanup is more
involved than with a non-stick pan
if you're willing to do the cleanup cast
iron pans are a worthwhile addition to
any kitchen
now let's talk about our third and final
pan stainless steel is without a doubt
my favorite pan to use in the kitchen
these pans are built tough and like cast
iron can be used on the stovetop
or in the oven they're particularly good
when you want a nice sear on a protein
you can truly cook everything with a
stainless steel pan
salmon sauteed vegetables risotto and
even eggs
the fear around using the stainless
steel pan is the idea that food will
stick
to prevent this you need to make sure
you're using a preheated pan
and the appropriate amount of oil so
here i have two chicken thighs and i'm
going to show you just how easy it is to
make sure your food doesn't stick
first things first let's preheat the pan
i'm going to add about two teaspoons of
oil
just enough to coat the bottom of the
pan once the oil begins to shimmer i'm
going to add the seasoned chicken
skin side down
i'm going to let the chicken rest in the
pan for a few minutes once the chicken
begins to pull away from the pan
it should be ready to flip see
it's so easy check out that beautiful
golden skin
i'm going to let them brown for a few
more minutes on the other side and then
i'm going to finish them off in the oven
after you remove the chicken from the
oven there's going to be some brown bits
at the bottom of the pan
this is called the foundation at this
point you can go ahead and scrub the pan
or what i prefer to do is take advantage
of the amazing flavor from the chicken
fat
and make a really simple pan sauce
reduce the stock for a few minutes
then add garlic thyme and a bit of
butter and stir
pour the sauce over the chicken and
you've got a great easy dinner
and a clean pan
so as you can see stainless steel can do
everything that a non-stick and a cast
iron can do
in my opinion it's the most versatile
pan out there
[Music]
uh